are you ready to learn some powerful
vocabulary and expressions for your
English let's do this so I meet then
you're a real-life fluency coach and I
want you to treat today's lesson a
little bit like quiz or a test first we
will watch this funny scene from friends
and pay special attention to any
vocabulary that you don't understand try
to guess the meaning through the context
of the scene and then we are going to
give you all the definitions and not
only the vocabulary expressions they'll
also show you some pronunciation and go
into any cultural context and then
finally you'll watch the scene a final
time without subtitles and you will test
what you learned
alright and I highly recommend as well
that you use an app like memorize or
unki so that you can remember all of
this new vocabulary forever also we have
a special present for you today it is
this PDF power lesson of which you can
download and deepen your learning with
the scene even more now let's watch the
scene
man this is weird if we realized cat
will crunch his eyebrows or actually on
his hat that's what's weird Joey the
man's been captain of a cereal for the
last 40 years what this boom you licked
and you put your licked in you put yeah
so why don't you see how gross that is I
mean that's like you're using my
toothbrush use my toothbrush that was
only because I used the red one to
unclog the drain
mine is the red one God can open worms
everywhere
hey why can't we use the same toothbrush
but we can use the same so because soap
is soap
it's self-cleaning alright well next
time you take a shower think about the
last thing I wash and the first thing
you wash man this is weird
this is weird man this is weird if we
realize that we'll crunches eyebrows are
actually on his hat eyebrows the strip
of hair above your eyes be careful not
to confuse eyebrows with eyelashes as
many learners do Captain Crunch is the
name and character of a famous breakfast
cereal in the United States as you can
see in the picture below Joey is right
about the fact that Captain Crunch his
eyebrows are on his hat that's what's
weird Joey the man's been captain of a
cereal for the last 40 years for the
last 40 years you licked and you put to
lick something the act of passing the
tongue over something it's what Joey
just did with the spoon as a replacement
to washing it with water and detergent
right thereafter Chandler says you lick
and you put which although it sounds
quite comical is not correct English by
put he actually means put away which is
a phrasal verb that means to orderly put
something back in its original place to
be correct he also needed to use an
object so you wick it and you put it
away or you lick the spoon and you put
it away so this is a good example of how
natives are often flexible with the
grammatical use of the language example
she told her kids to put the toys away
once they are done playing do you want
to understand natives without getting
lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles and be sure to hit the
subscribe button and that little belt so
you can get our very newest lessons
every week you lick them you put yeah so
so think so
with a rising intonation that is as if
asking a question is used to tell
someone
that's something it does not matter so
what is a common alternative with the
same meaning we use this only in
informal conversation here's an example
of how we might use so in a conversation
she might tell someone so no one will
believe her why don't you see how gross
that is why don't you see how gross that
is I mean that's like you're using my
toothbrush gross we say that something
is gross when we find something
disgusting or unpleasant for example you
could say picking something off the
floor and putting it in your mouth is
gross gross is an adjective that we can
express as an action by using the
phrasal verb gross out example his dirty
fingernails really grossed me out
toothbrush the type of brush that you
use for cleaning your teeth that was
only because I used the red one to
unclog the drain unclog the drain to
clog something is to create a blockage
that obstructs the passing of water
through a pipe to unclog is to remove
such blockage to allow water or another
fluid to flow freely if your sink is
clogged then you need to call a plumber
to unclog it a drain is a channel of
pipes that carry off liquid waste when
trying to unclog a drain using a plunger
is not just more hygienic than using a
toothbrush but also more effective an
open worms everywhere
can open worms everywhere this is a
funny yet unconventional way in which
Chandler describes the situation using
the idiom to open a can of worms it is
unconventional because we never say it
like that we commonly say for example I
don't want to open that can of worms
this expression usually has a negative
meaning
that is by tempting to solve a problem
you accidentally complicate the
situation even more by exposing the
truth and causing more trouble example
giving my secretary a small raise open
to count of worms at the firm because
everyone found out about it and now they
want the same salary increase hey why
can't we use the same toothbrush but we
can use the same so so a substance used
for washing the body be careful not to
confuse its pronunciation with soup one
is soap and the other is soup remember
to download your free present for the
scene of PDF power lessons which will
help you to deepen your knowledge with
the scene remember all of the vocabulary
and expressions improve your
pronunciation and even learn a little
bit more about American culture you can
download that for free by clicking up
here man this was weird if we realize
Pat will crunch his eyebrows or actually
on his hat that's what's weird Joey the
man's been captain of a cereal for the
last 40 years
what the spoon you licked and you put
your licked in your pot yeah so why
don't you see how gross that is I mean
that's like you're using my toothbrush
brush that was only because I used the
red one to unclog the drain mine is the
red one God can open worms everywhere
hey why can't we use the same toothbrush
but we can use the same so because soap
is soap it's self-cleaning all right
well next time you take a shower think
about the last thing I wash and the
first thing you wash oh yeah I hope you
understood a lot more the second time
around and had fun learning with that
scene we are excited to help you on your
journey into real life women see so be
sure to hit that subscribe button so you
can get our newest lessons every single
week and download your PDF power lesson
present I also made a playlist of other
scenes teaching you a vocabulary so be
sure to check that out and I have
another video I think you are really
going to like now go out there and kick
ass with your English oh yeah